over the memorial day weekend millions
of us we all honored the heroic service
of the brave men and women that died
defending
our freedoms our liberties and our
country for many families it was a
somber weekend of remembrance
for those loved ones who made the
ultimate sacrifice
when we do quietly reflect on the
blessings that are liberty
that we all kind of usually take for
granted if we're honest
so many people made the ultimate
sacrifice for all of
us but for joe biden kamala harris oh
it's just a
nice long weekend have a great long
weekend
no joe and no kamala on friday biden
kicking off the national holiday
tweeting a picture of himself with an
ice cream cone and a caption that reads
stay cool this weekend folks and not to
be outdone as kamala harris tweeting a
picture of herself
smiling from ear to ear enjoy the long
weekend
with no mention of why we have a long
weekend which would be memorial day
whatsoever
that kind of brings back memories of
obama he didn't know the difference
between veterans day memorial day
remember he referred to navy corpsman
navy corpsman he did it three times in
one speech
and the dnc which tweeted out this
celebratory memorial day picture of
obama with an ice cream cone in 2015
well fully honored our fallen soldiers
and then celebrated the long weekend by
staying cool at a french restaurant
in washington d.c called it a diplomat
and on friday joe also spoke to our
military members in a base in virginia
but
his prepared remarks went off the rails
when joe made
more creepy remarks about a very young
girl in the audience
then of course he stammered and stumbled
and bumbled like he usually does but
yeah this was particularly creepy
i'm especially honored to share the
stage with brittany
and jordan and nathan and margaret
catherine
i i love those barrettes in her hair man
i tell you what i look at her she looks
like she's 19 years old sitting there
with her
like a little lady in her legs caught
okay that kind of makes my skin crawl
don't know about you
if it doesn't i don't know what will at
least we have improvement
no hair sniffing no unsolicited back
rubs like usual
meanwhile vice president harris she had
a cringe-worthy moment of her own during
a commencement address
at the u.s naval academy on friday she
obsessed about green energy
made a woke joke that almost nobody
found funny except for her
and then she did what she usually does
starts laughing
somewhat uncontrollably somewhat
uncomfortably
look you are electrical engineers
who will soon help convert solar
and wind energy into power
convert solar and wind energy
into combat power
and just ask any marine today
would she rather carry 20 pounds of
batteries
or a rolled up solar panel
and i am positive she will tell you a
solar panel
and so would he
it wasn't funny and i don't think they
got it
with china russia iran all teaming up an
unholy alliance against the u.s
and every country besides them in the
middle east meaning the iranians
waging war cyber attacks proxy wars
around the world members of our military
facing serious challenges
woe kamala seems more interested in
solar panels
and the fight for social justice it's
not only tone deaf but also kind of
scary and chilling
hostile actors in russia just pulled off
what is a second major
cyber attack first it was against
america's largest oil and gas pipeline
system
impacting the entire east coast of the
united states
biden did nothing now the world's
largest meat supplier has been disrupted
again according to reports by russian
hackers
jbs processes a quarter of america's
beef
one-fifth of our country's pork and they
operate a couple of dozen chicken
processing facilities
all across the country matter of fact
they probably have fed every one of you
watching tonight
that's not good and it means that
already high meat prices
they're just going to get higher and
higher and higher so joe
your president what the hell are you
going to do to the
hold the russians this hostile regime
this hostile actor putin accountable
and sadly it appears that joe per usual
is going to do nothing in fact his
one-on-one meeting with putin
now it's still on the books for june the
19th make no mistake and let me go on
record
up here and just lay it out this
summit's a bad idea
putin will be assessing and he's not
going to see joe through
the prism of the media mob in big tech
he will be assessing joe biden
and i'm pretty confident he'll come to
the same conclusion that many of you
have
that joe is weak he is frail
a total complete cognitive mess and a
hollow
shadow of his former self and putin will
use
that firsthand assessment and walk all
over him
and the u.s and he probably will leave
laughing at our country
and leave embolden feeling he can get
away with anything
for once i would argue joe needs to take
his little sippy cup
go to the basement take a nappy if he's
really good we'll give him a bedtime
story
meanwhile according to an explosive
report from the new york post
in 2015 the vice president then biden
was a regular at this dc hot spot where
he frequently met with his son's sketchy
foreign business partners
that includes oligarchs other
individuals from
ukraine kazakhstan and russia which
brings us to a couple of serious
unanswered questions
why was the vice president meeting with
zero experienced hunters
sketchy business partners and why did
joe lie
again and again and again and again
and say he's never discussed his foreign
business dealings with hunter
clearly those foreign nationals were
paying for
access uh did joe get a cut
you know where where's the special
counsel looking into this corruption
so is the corrupt biden family syndicate
business now
impacting america's foreign policy
and is anybody in the media mob
will you ever once actually build up a
little bit of courage
ask joe the questions that you know
you'd be asking every second every
minute of every hour of every day if it
was trump
of course you'll need to head to
delaware and shout the question from the
beach because tomorrow
joey is taking a sippy cup back to his
beach house
marking the 12th trip to delaware in
fourth four months
now keep in mind he only starts his day
at 9
30 starts getting ready for betty bye at
seven
he's never seen the show that i know of
as president zero experience hunter is
now under a criminal investigation
but he's a liberal he'll probably get
away with it only conservatives get life
in jail for jaywalking
of course hunter's charges international
money laundering tax fraud
but outside the new york post fox a
couple of other outlets
biden is protected by the democrats the
media mob and of course
big tech people that pretend to be
journalists hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else